en abril de 2020 el mundo de Karla se
vino abajo en plena pandemia descubrió
durante un examen de rutina que tenía un
cáncer maligno en el pezón
el diagnóstico fue complicado porque
porque me pidió en un momento de
sufrimiento
un mes Antes había perdido a mi madre
los médicos se retiraron la areola de su
seno además Carla Tuvo que pasar por un
ciclo de quimioterapia
al final esta mujer consiguió vencer la
enfermedad a sus 41 años solo desea
volver a la normalidad
me siento un poco yo me siento un poco
mutilada no tengo mucho valor de mirarme
en el espejo porque sé que está faltando
una parte de mí misma
[Música]
Hoy es el día en que Carla va a
recuperar su autoestima gracias al
trabajo solidario de un tatuador
hace 11 años Beto realiza tatuajes
gratuitos a mujeres que perdieron sus
mamás
ya te hicieron un injerto alguna vez
Beto examina los pechos de Carla para
poder copiar exactamente su pezón
es un procedimiento rápido pero muy
preciso en poco más de media hora Beto
tatúa la areola completa el resultado es
espectacular
yo no veía Carla veía otra persona Ahora
estoy viendo a la Carla de verdad
decenas de mujeres han vuelto a sonreír
gracias a la generosidad de este
profesional que no cobra por este
servicio
otros tatuadores en el mundo podrían ver
eso sensibilizarse y ayudar otros
tatuadores podrían unirse a ser la misma
cosa porque no cuesta nada es un trabajo
de 40 minutos que va a dar felicidad a
una mujer por el resto de su vida
Beto sigue cuidando de esas mujeres
incluso después del tatuaje alguna como
Marcia vuelve a por otro un lazo rosa
que identifica a las pacientes
oncológicas